hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve the problem evaluate reverse
polish notation quite a mouthful but
basically this problem is about what the
meaning of that term even means and it's
just kind of a way to compute
arithmetic expressions and the only
operations we're really going to be
doing in this case are going to be the
simple ones add subtract multiply and
divide a one note that they tell us
though is division between two integers
should basically round towards zero
since i'm going to be doing this in
python though if you you know take uh
some values and do integer division
between them they always round down
which is not rounding towards zero
necessarily because imagine if we had
negative 3 divided by 2 that's negative
1.5 it rounds down to negative 2 in
python but that's not what we want to do
but there's a trick in python that you
can do to make it round towards zero so
we can take care of that if you're using
java though i think it automatically
rounds towards zero same with like c
plus plus in most languages uh one thing
we're told though in terms of the rn rpn
rpn expression is that it's always going
to be valid which is good so we don't
really have to worry about too many edge
cases there's never going to be some
divide by zero or anything crazy like
that so now what does rpn even mean well
let's take a look at this example so
we're given a 2 a 1
then a plus operator then a 3 and then a
multiply operator now the way uh this is
gonna work is we're gonna be reading
from left to right we're gonna be
reading the inputs uh so first one was a
two next one is a one when we reach an
operator though what exactly are we
supposed to do well any operator in this
case is going to be applied to the
previous two values and like i said
there's not going to be edge cases so
we're guaranteed that there are going to
be two previous values so in this case
what we would do is replace these this
two and this one
by adding them together so where it's
going to be replaced with a
three right so we can kind of forget
these and we already used this plus
operator so we can kind of cross it out
as well now we have a 3 again
so i'm going to be kind of writing it
down here just to kind of you know
basically say that we've seen that 3
before now we have the multiply operator
it's going to be applied to the two
previous values now in the actual input
itself you can see that the the previous
value was a 3 and the value before that
was a plus operator when we say it's
going to be applied to the two previous
values that's not what we mean we don't
want to apply it to another operator
right we mean the two previous values
that came so you can see that we had a
three and then the one before that was a
one but remember this two and this one
they were replaced by this three and
then we had a second 3 which we wrote
down here so this multiply is going to
be applied to these two values so we can
multiply both of them and then replace
them with the result which in this case
is going to be a 9. so you can see that
that is our result and you can see that
it is correct if you know the data
structure or you're familiar with the
data structure a stack and you've used
that in other problems before i think
this problem is pretty simple to figure
out that a stack will be useful here
because basically each operator is going
to be applied to the previous values
right but in the case of this 2 the
previous values are going to be removed
from the stack right and then replaced
with the new value which is a three so
you know as we read through the input
each value here is going to be added to
the stack anytime we reach an operator
the previous two values are going to be
removed from the stack and then we're
gonna do the operation on them so in
this case two plus one and then we're
gonna take the result of that which is
three and then push it back onto the
stack and that's kind of what i was
getting at when i was doing the drawing
explanation so really quickly let's
actually run through an example with a
stack and just to make this problem a
bit more interesting let's replace this
uh
plus operator with actually a subtract
and this multiply with a divide because
uh it's going to be a little bit
different with these two operations
because with plus these two are going to
be added right two plus one but when you
have subtract which order are they going
to be subtracted well the intuitive one
would be two minus one because that's
the order that they appear in but one
minus two could be possible right well
in this case if you looked at the second
example i think they clarify that yes
it's going to be this way right 2 minus
1. let's run through this with a stack
very quickly so we read the first value
it's a 2 we add it to our stack second
value is a one we add it to our stack
next we get the subtract operator what
does that mean that means we pop these
values from our stack and then do the
operation so in this case it was two
minus one that's going to be a one over
here next value is a 3 we add it to the
stack next we have a divide operator so
in this case it's going to be the same
order that the values appear in so 1
divided by 3 we're going to round
towards 0. so in this case it's actually
gonna be zero right so we pop this pop
this uh and then replace it with a zero
and we're guaranteed since this is
always going to be valid that we're only
gonna be left with a single value in our
stack so that's the value we're gonna
return so in this case the answer is 0.
so that's pretty much the entire
solution
now we can code it up but i just want to
mention that the overall time complexity
is going to be big o of n because we're
just reading through the input string
adding each value to the stack and
removing it at most once each so you
know the time complexity is two times n
in other words it's big o of n uh the
memory complexity since we do have the
stack is also going to be big o of n so
now let's code it up let's code it up
like i said we're going to need a single
data structure in this problem which is
going to be our stack in python you can
just use a list
and then most of this problem is just
going to be boilerplate once you realize
that a stack works for this problem then
it's just about coding it up so what
we're going to do is just iterate
through every character in our tokens
input and then just have a bunch of
conditional statements the first one is
if the character
well there's five cases remember it
could be one of the four operators or it
could be any other character and any
other character basically means that
it's a digit or some number right so
let's basically make those conditions so
first is that it's
plus and let me just kind of you know
copy and paste this stuff and then get
uh
it updated so
the cases are plus minus multiply and
divide and then the last fifth case is
where it's something else and if it's
something else that means it's a number
and that's the simplest case of all
because that means we can just take that
character and then append it to our
stack but it's a character remember but
we should probably convert it into a
number before we actually add it to our
stack because remember what we want to
return is a number not a character okay
so now let's start with the plus
condition well remember what i said we
can just pop from our stack twice and
then add those values together and then
append that to the stack so for this
it's actually pretty simple as well we
pop from the stack twice take the return
values add them together and then append
that to the stack so that the result is
added to the sac pretty simple and for
multiply that's also going to be almost
the exact the same thing right instead
of plus we're going to be doing
multiplication so let's you know just
copy paste and then update that as well
it's going to be a little bit more
tricky though for subtract and divide
because the order that we're popping it
in is not the order that we want to
apply that subtract and divide
operations so
for subtract well again we are going to
pop twice because we want to get those
two values that were popped so let's do
that this is
let's call them just a and b arbitrarily
you could call them anything that you
want but when we
subtract them we want to subtract we
want to take the one that was popped
second and subtract it from the one that
was popped first so b minus a and then
take that and then append it to our
stack so this though is going to be very
similar to what we do in our divide
operation down here we're going to pop
two values and then in that same order b
and then a we're going to divide them
rather than subtract them but in python
when you do this this is actually
decimal division but we want to round it
towards zero so to do that we can
actually just call the int function
which will convert it to an integer and
also round it towards zero at the same
time so that's pretty much the entire
code you can see it's mostly just a
bunch of boilerplate but once all that's
done let's go ahead and return the
single value that is guaranteed to be in
the stack stack at index zero and then
make sure that our code works by running
it and as you can see on the left yes it
does and it's very efficient so i really
hope that this was helpful if it was
please like and subscribe it really
supports the channel a lot consider
checking out my patreon where you can
further support the channel and
hopefully i'll see you pretty soon
thanks for watching